aging affects all of us and puts us at  risk of different diseases  this includes cancer and alzheimer's  disease given the current changes in  demographics this is putting pressure on  the healthcare sector  however an area of current excitement is  the idea of instead of treating these  different diseases separately  to instead target the aging process  itself on my channel i've mentioned  a variety of different supplements that  have some scientific evidence that seem  to suggest  they have some potential as anti-aging  compounds  one compound that i recently mentioned  is alpha-ketoglutarate  otherwise referred to as akg this  compound is naturally found within our  cells  and plays an important role in the  metabolic pathway however as we age it's  been shown that the levels of akg  decline interestingly in a recent study  mice were given akg delivered as a  calcium salt  and it was found that the akg could  extend health span  in both male and female mice